I won't give you sweets Keira it's hard ah
go All-you-can-eat sweets and all-you-can-play pranks It's the start of a wonderful day
Go out and get busy I'm busy with netoge You can only imitate People who have no veto have no right of refusal
Halloween is strict
And you don't have that weird look
I really like events, because this is the world of humans, so it's better to have
fun.
Isn't that just a dangerous guy? Surely this uni must still have sweets
?
Come on, let's forget about it and let the soul make the abnormalities in the figure.
It's okay, yeah, Halloween doesn't have much of a religious meaning anymore, and
the devil needs to be flexible about that,
so I don't think it's necessary to be so serious about
language events.  Come
to think of it, I had one of those costumes
.